فايروس كورونا حتى وان هدات وتيره انتشاره
ومتحوراته فهو من حين لاخر يعود للواجهه
لكن يبقى السؤال الذي لم يتم الاجابه عليه
منذ ثلاث سنوات كيف تسربت اختلفت الدول
والمؤسسات حول مصادر الجائحه بين نظريه
التسريب غير المتعمد والمصدر الحيواني
نظريه التسرب يدعمها وجود اكثر من حاله
انتشار تسرب للفيروسات من معامل بحثيه
عالميا وخاصه في الصين اسار احد افراد
عائله فيروسات كورونا تسرب مرتين في عام
2003 مر في سنغافوره ومره في تايوان قبل
ان يتسرب الفيروس مرتين ايضا من مختبر في
بكين عام 2004 وبالتالي من البديهي ان
تعتمد نظريات التسريب على مختبر مهان
فيروسات كورونا هي صلب ابحاثه وهنا يبرز
اسم شيء جنني مديره
علميا ما قد يفسر تناقض نتائج تحقيقات
المؤسسات الامريكيه
تاكد مدير الاف بي اي مره اخرى ان فيروس
كورونا خرج من مختبر في الصين المهم في
هذا التقدير الصادر عن هذا المبنى في
واشنطن انه متوسط الثقه اي ان لديه
اثباتات افضل من التي في حوزه وزاره
الطاقه الامريكيه وتقديرها هو منخفض الثقه
ولكن المهم ايضا هو ان هناك وكالتين من
اصل تسعه تقول في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان سبب هو خروج الفيروس من
مختبر فيما تقول الوكالات الاخرى انه بسبب
حادث في احد اسواقي وهون السبب في هذه
الاختلافات يعود الى ان كل وكاله تعمل
لوحدها والصين لا تتعاون
[موسيقى]
اذا
ظهر الفيروس في وهران منطقيا اذا الصين هي
المنشا لكن اين في الصين وهنا تنقسم
الروايات والفرضيات فهل خرج من سوقه ونان
الماكولات البحريه بانتقاله من الحيوان
الى الانسان ام من مختبر ووهان والفرضيه
التي تعترض بكين بشده عليها لانه يحملها
مسؤوليه الجائحه ويسيس القضيه على حد
وصفها الصين تقبلت بعد ضغوط دوليه دفعت
بها الولايات المتحده زياره فريق منظمه
الصحه العالميه لها في يناير 2021 لكنها
رفضت تكرار التجربه واجراء تحقيق جديد
طلبته المنظمه خاصه بعد ترجيحها فرضيه
المختبر عكست هنا بكين المؤامره سعت لوضع
واشنطن تحت طائله الاتهام والملاحقه ضخت
زخما كبيرا في حمله دعائيه لتكون قاعده
فورد ديفيك العسكريه في ولايه ميريلاند
تحت المجهر غير انها لم تنجح لكن هل كان
هناك ما يدعم فرضيتها القاعده المنشاه منذ
ثلاثينات القرن الماضي تحوي مختبرا
بيولوجيا هاما وهنا نحن في يوليو 2019
اغلقت القاعده الامريكيه والمختبر ابوابه
بشكل مفاجئ والسبب انتشار التهاب رئوي بين
عامليه ومنه الى ولايات مختلفه
شبهت خطوره اعراضه لايبولا الفيروس الاخضر
قبل ظهور الاخطر الفيروس الصيني كما روج
له الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب ظهر في
بلاده في ديسمبر 2019 وهذا كشف لمعاهد
الصحه الوطنيه الامريكيه اي في نفس الوقت
الذي اعلنت الصين عن اكتشافه